it's time for screen junkies movie
fights
holy crap hold on your loot crate's it's
movie fights come on everybody
another fun-filled action-packed
Throwdown with three great cinema minds
ready to be challenged by our questions
and yeah we'll see what happens first oh
he's a great friend of the show he's a
writer you know him from Wonder Woman 77
and the upcoming Supergirl not upcoming
it's out now mark and Draco man thank
you for bringing the merch to plug yeah
very cool congratulations on this can't
wait to open it up and yeah we might
have a question centric to this very
thing stay tuned this young man he wiped
the floor with the competition last time
around our first pitch the first ever
shutout and movie fights history you won
no one scored a point off you is like
the you know free sports fans on no
hitter and you know I'm from the real
rejects Greg Alba thanks I'm happy to be
I mean I'm still nervous as hell though
I mean Ken's one of the funniest guys
have ever seen truck movie fights
champion usually when I see mark fight
I'm like yeah yeah I agree with mark
when I watch him fight so I'm like all
right here we go all right I'm nervous
today but I'm gonna do my best just want
to have fun and do my best bear in mind
you mentioned drunk movie fights you're
going against a so pretend to show this
is like when this is like when Superman
reversed the the crystals at the
fortress of solitude and you know this
man needs no introduction you know miss
the pit-boss
he is the delightful the drunk movie
fights champion can nap doc yeah and I
right before the show started dad
mentioned he had some alcohol but I
didn't want to bring it here and I you
know that's all right I understand I you
know I can't always fight drunk and
that's probably a good thing
I'm happy to be here and I'm out for
revenge because when I'll go through
that perfect game as you said this is a
hitter he did so with the expense in
part to my podcast partner in the
afternoons josh mokuba so I am here for
revised version OSH alright and you know
what we'll see if you can exact
revenge judging that will be myself and
a couple fellas right over here on the
Dan cam Dan Merle fact-check and holding
it down judging what don't you do dan oh
so many things how but it's somebody the
name here Dan you are an amazing man
with numbers and you have a great hand
on the box office who's gonna win the
box office this weekend ooh
people are saying the Meg but the Meg's
coming in a little low I still think
it's gonna be number one but I think
Mission Impossible fall it's gonna give
it a bigger run for its money than
people yeah right on thank you Dan for
holding it down and there is no Daniel
Radford today oh but we have a a very
suitable and a more than adequate you
know we've got an excellent replacement
right there lawns and lawns lawn Harris
that's me thanks for having me do you
want to tell them how you will be acting
as a conduit ship our people so I will
be I will be voting on behalf of the
viewers like you that are out there
watching this on the internet if you
want to vote you just go to the actual
YouTube page itself
make sure you of your annotations turned
on because you can vote in a little box
that will pop up in the top right hand
corner of the video if the new question
is not showing up for you just turn off
your annotations and turn them back on
to refresh the page and they will show
up and then I will be telling a pal and
all of our fighters how you guys voted
on that fight excellent law and I
couldn't have said it better myself nor
would I want to so and here's a little
refresher on how our game works so
there's gonna be three regular round
questions where we'll hear from
everybody they'll fight it out and then
after that we the top two scorers from
the first three rounds move into the
speed round and the first player to
achieve four points will walk out of
here the victor the other guys will
thumb a ride home so we're ready to get
this party started
yes sir absolutely ready all right JT II
dropped that package
[Music]
[Applause]
yes JGE best package in the biz
alright let us move to our fraud
question touchin that at all you know
what good literally and figuratively um
okay so as Dan Merle mentioned the Meg
opens this weekend besides the original
jaws which is a pretty
what's the all-time greatest shark movie
besides jaws what's the all-time
greatest shark movie start with the man
to my left mark and Draco um I when I
got this question I started looking up
all the shark movies and I've seen all
of them which is weird and most of them
there there's a big difference between
Jaws and what's the second best one but
the second best one I believe is deep
blue sea for many reasons one it's
ridiculous it's it's absolutely
ridiculous it features the worst song
ever Cool J's pair of the parrot for
most of the movie Thomas Jane is the
leading man I wonder who turned it down
before it got to him it's got the
airplane of shark movies and that's
great plus the thing is most known for
is that great Sam Jackson Z and this is
a spoiler alert if you haven't seen it
you know after 20 years but okay when
he's giving that great great bombastic
ripoff of Quint monologue and before he
finishes it a shark eats him it's just
it's great it balances out it's almost
like Paul Verhoeven's Jaws that's what
this one is like it's probably the most
entertaining film Renny Harlin has ever
directed gotcha
alright deep Lucy from Mark Greg yes so
when I was thinking about my answer for
this question actually came pretty quick
because it was posed as what's the
second what's the best shark movie other
than jaws and I thought about what makes
jaws such a great movie and there's a
variety of reasons but I tend to think
of genuine suspenseful horror backed
with awesome Direction great
performances great character work and I
feel like most shark movies like deep
blue sea and Ken's choice which you guys
will hear in a second usually shark
movies nowadays rely on so bad it's good
and there's only one shark movie I've
seen in recent years that genuinely got
a good response for being a good
and that is the shallows I think the
shallows actually has a wonderful
performance by Blake Lively great
character work it gives you a singular
shark villain unlike these other movies
that rely on a quantity of sharks the
shark actually feels like a villain in
this movie
there's unique stylish direction there's
some real thrills and there are some
real terrifying moments it doesn't rely
on being so bad it's good because it's
actually just good alright Greg actually
choosing a good movie in his opinion the
shallows Ken what do you got I
absolutely agree with Mark and Rickon
one thing there is number one and then
there is the rest so I'm gonna go for
memorable I'm gonna go for loud
bombastic ridiculous and yeah a little
bit of so bad it's good but we're gonna
dive into why that works but we are
first gonna be dealing with sharknado
shark NATO
alright sci-fi classic and you're saying
the first one narc not sharknado 9 if
you know about it I would have gone jaws
2 if we're gonna go in that red no
sharknado alright there we have it you
know fight it out there's blood in the
water okay well first of all this is
movie fights right yeah sharknado was a
TV film it was not released theatrically
so it to get a limited get a limited
theatrical release mark and Rick oh I
did look that up and it was not eligible
for an Academy Award this year and how
it is more popular shark yes when you
think about shark movies I actually
think Greg's honest I get what you're
saying there's a science to your choice
I love the reef I mean open water scoop
sneezing shallows I can't remember which
one yours yours is of the realistic
takes on shark woman the problem with
the realistic takes on shark movies is
you can't compete with Jaws jaws is a
perfect movie so you have to lean into
it you're gonna have a shark in the
movie you can't try to be scary because
jaws has done all that I can't talk
about how serious the shallows is if
there's a character named Jonathan
Livingston Seagull well no that's just a
sassy go Steven Seagal whoo see it's a
character that's just a burden but
really it's not even a literary
reference
just a bird that she's stranded with on
this rock blade Scylla better recognize
I think no I think Blake if you look up
the reviews on the movie many people
praised Blake Lively's performance in
that film there's one moment in that
movie where she's watching a man meeting
to bow her by a shark and the camera
just pans it on her face and I find it
to be such an effective moment because
she's not talking you're watching the
horror on her face develop so you're
feeling the horror she's going through I
remember being in the theater there's a
moment where she's talking into a GoPro
and she's saying a goodbye message I'm
gonna be vulnerable here I remember
crying I remember hearing a bunch of
people around me crying and there's so
many gasp in the audience I would not
say this movie is not scary because I
remember watching us in the theaters and
here I didn't think it wasn't scary I
said it pales in comparison when you try
and make a movie that is a that is more
closely aligned to the tone of the
original jaws it just makes me think of
the original job I takes me out of that
my feeling I feel like deep blue sea
trot is unintentionally bad that scene
was intentionally bad deep blue seas on
intention and I think take away Sam
Jackson's great moment one of the great
I think you take that away I don't
remember anything to that movie other
than Thomas Jane badly is a lead it's
it's it is in his unintentionally
b-movie as most of Renny Harlin's latter
part of his career but that's a separate
note there I that's what I think that's
I'm doubling down on this crime doubling
down on you on you want I and ziering
with a chainsaw I reread looking at him
if you go to the street what's your
favorite movie outside of jobs people in
your big I said there's all these ones
but I like sharknado a sharknado should
it doesn't count because always was the
West wasn't the what pump the population
thinks is a good movie but you should
never trust the majority of the
population Velveeta is the best-selling
cheese product in America it doesn't
mean it's good
NATO it started it started tickets
sharknadoes the whole intent is to be
the worst movie it could possibly be so
I would say it's the best at being the
worst but that doesn't make it the best
shark movie since javis between
sharknado and and deep Lucy is the deep
blue sea running Harlin's trying to make
a good science fiction thriller but he's
also the camp is unintentional and camp
has to be on campus you guys have your
try
wacky it generally isn't you guys are
both admitting your movies are bad
though I mean if you look up shallows on
Rotten Tomatoes it has the highest
audience score out of any of these
movies people respond great to this film
because it actually is scary it has good
character word which wouldn't be
Direction money at the box office it
doesn't really count for anything in
advertising though audience scores
different because you're actually
judging the movie the box-office shows
how many people actually paid to see the
movie yeah but the shells which is an
absolutely good performance but Blake
Lively I'm not gonna snark it out but I
know andraka will and I love him for but
I think it doesn't set itself apart I'm
telling the reef open water
47 leagues meters down leagues or meters
I don't know I'm from America I think
all those try to be jaws but if you
can't be jaws be something entirely
different both your movies have specific
oh ma jizz - your film is trying to be
jaws meets Jurassic Park your film has
lines that are straight up you know
dodging jaws it's possibly danced away
with the psychotic stalking but it
actually works it's actually effective
it's actually a real moment sharknado
has it a shark ripping a roof off a car
you have Tara Reid's performance you
have he's trying to do a good job in
that movie that's what bums me out about
that performance is for everyone else do
her job everyone else is knowing what
they're in for in terror Reid is
actually trying to do a good job but is
failing at it your movie has characters
that are super generic so much
convenient plot points your movies rely
on sci-fi sharks mine is the only one it
feels close to a sense of realism in the
film your movies are just decided their
movies works because of their stupid
that's the shark in in shallows is
related to the shark in Jaws for where
this time it's personal it's a fish it's
gonna move on if it can't get food
there's other food out there it's
ridiculous that the shark hit well then
the shark has a better arc than Blake
Lively in the movie but it's still
ridiculous if this shark would be
lurking and watching likely has a
complete arc in the movie she finds
herself by the end of the film
your movies like the I don't know you
guys were talking about sci-fi sharks
here there's no sense of realism to your
films
III think the shark in my movie it's one
shark and it feels like an actual
antagonist an actual villain your sharks
rely on specially sharknado relies on
quantity of ridiculousness do something
silly mine is the only one you can
actually take seriously when you're
watching the movie and you're talking
about best shark movie since jaws it is
the only one between these three that
fit any of the qualities great jaws I'm
gonna ask you to go ahead and make some
final thoughts right now continue that
roll that into final thoughts sure thing
okay I have so many notes today and I
didn't really get to go on I think both
of your movies rely on the fact that
they're so bad it's good terrible acting
terrible effects non memorable
characters your movie is about I want to
see a bunch of sharks get killed I don't
care about the humans your movies about
I want to see all these humans get
killed cuz I don't care about the humans
my movies the only one that has a
protagonist that you're worried for you
fear for her life
you're afraid she's gonna die so by the
time spoilers when she kills the shark
I'm her be everyone applauded in the
theater when that happened because you
were so worried she was actually going
to die it's the only one you care about
a character has a beautiful color
palette throughout some unique shots
there's a shot in the ocean when the
sharks coming that is straight-up rip
that Jurassic world falling kingdoms
straight up rip off further I don't know
if that dinosaurs manasa Soros whatever
it's called divorce or yes
there you go Ken so yeah like mine is
the only one is a movie that can
actually be taken seriously that
provides horror thrills and good
character your films they're just just
stupid sci-fi movies that are only known
for being stupid alright thank you Greg
Ken I think Greg is absolutely right
about one thing the shallows is a very
well-put-together movie but it just
didn't set itself apart you can get it
in a lot of different different areas I
want someone yelling what the hell
they're sharks in the street if I can't
have the seriousness of Jaws I want to
have the over-the-topness it had one
point like three million viewers and
then by the third showing it was set in
records at 2.1 million that was released
in the theater so it actually counts for
this argument here I want over-the-top
deep blue sea Marc himself said it's a
rip it's a ripoff of Quint that's the
best moment is that you can kind of take
an O monster too
jaws where mine just sets itself apart
it puts it over this corner and more
people will be talking about sharknado
for years to come and popular vote is
sometimes the vote mark and Draco well
the question was and what what is the
best shark movie that evokes the
feelings and terror of Jaws it was what
is the best shark movie after Jaws and
deep blue sea does have steaks in it
when your biggest star of your movie
it's killed 10 minutes into the movie 20
minutes into the movie you know no one
is safe none of the characters are a
little cardboard sure but that they're
embracing the fact that we can't compete
with the seriousness and the actual
terror of Jaws we're gonna lean into the
Grand Guignol of sharks eating people
and take it to the next level this is
this movie knows what it is it embraces
what it is and it's the only duty of the
three the there's actual risk for the
leads because two of the three leads die
in the movie including the female lead
that's unheard of you never know who's
gonna get eaten in this movie so there
are stakes for the characters all right
mark breaking off a little Grand Guignol
and his ants I love that all right thank
you John time good fun good fight good
fight a real a real a real dog fight in
the water
damn facts I have a lot of facts on this
Oh sharknado was indeed not qualified or
eligible to be considered for the
Academy Awards it did release and was
released a handful of theaters after
premiered on sci-fi but the rules among
others is that it cannot have premiered
on any other format before it premieres
in Los Angeles because we're elitist
however it was deemed eligible for this
show so yes that's the only eligibility
that matters on movie fights hmm deep
blue sea was the biggest hit domestic
box-office wise out of these films
although it had a budget that was about
four times the shallows so they actually
made a kind of a similar amount of money
shadows made 119 million deep blue sea
164 but you could argue that the
shallows because of his budget was a
bigger hit and that it might have made
more money a gross profit but that's
that's a whole other thing that only I
care about I can it was 47 meters down
you might have a thing of 20,000 Leagues
Under the Sea that's the comic book I
like meters instead of leagues arresting
Lee both European you
to measure neither for us America yeah
neither one of the things that US
American dummies learned in our schools
the Mosasaurus maybe was the Daiwa greg
yeah and then looking at critical and
audience favorites on Rotten Tomatoes
this was brought out many times the
critical favorite out of these three
movies was actually shark but it has way
less reviews weightless from critic the
audience favorite was the shallows 59%
although audiences did not give a stamp
of approval to eat any of these three
movies when they were giving their
metrics to Rotten Tomatoes so there you
go gotcha thank you for comprehensively
breaking that down Dan Merle okay so
mark I'm gonna talk about you first and
that means you're not gonna win this
point I feel like they dinged you real
good when they said it was unintentional
comedy and so when you're saying that
the director set out to accomplish
something that he didn't accomplish and
actually accidentally came up with some
messy weird other thing that's kind of
fun at times I feel like they're poked
too many holes in your boat and you got
eaten by the shark bye-bye mark here
comes more okay Greg comes down to Greg
and Ken for me and it was a rivalry it
was it was Greg all the way for me until
I started thinking about this question
what's the greatest shark movie that's
up the best movie the greatest shark
movie what it could be most fun most
bombast there's a lot that can go into
that and I feel like more so than Greg
Ken really sold me on the power of his
movie and how Greg's movie falls back
into the pack of other films like it so
as the greatest at wording in the
question greatest all-time shark movie
after Jaws sort of Londo and NAT sock
Dan I agree with you in the sense that
that was a very compelling argument from
Ken that he did brought up a very good
point to Greg's pick about how does it
distinguish itself from the pack as far
as other movies like open water etc but
I think that Greg had a good answer for
that and what ultimately put me over the
top was that I thought mark and Ken both
had qualifiers attached to their picks I
think Mark sort of was just like well
you're never gonna be jaws so I'm gonna
go something that has the sort of camp
fact
so I'm picking deep blue sea and Ken was
saying you know well I'm gonna go with
the movie you know I this is what I like
I personally enjoy these kind of things
but I thought Greg made the best
argument for why his movie the
performance the the craft of it the
suspense and everything else made it the
better the better movie overall so I'm
actually going with Greg all right it is
one one young Brandon Greg cried during
the shallows yeah Blake Lively you're
all right so we're locked up at one one
lon oh it's obviously we have one clear
winner here it is not sharknado that was
pulling up the rear 17% of the so it
came down to deep blue sea at the
shelves but big wind from the shallow
seas of Greg wins the audience oh sweet
yes yeah you took a bite out of the
first round and also we're pulling for
Shark Tale on this one did not come that
was my second one of them mark and I
were talking before the round and he
mentioned West Side Story the sharks and
the giant the Jamie Foxx movie the Jamie
Foxx football team and Sunday the Miami
sharks Miami sharks categories best
shark movie that doesn't feature actual
shiny sharp people in the comments to
are giving us pool shark movies and card
shark moves as well oh yeah come on any
color am I sure yeah yeah Minnesota yeah
take it back alright so Greg you take a
1-0 lead let's move into round number
two going on
all right it's about to get spooky break
out the the creepypasta Slenderman is
coming to theaters this October what is
the next internet meme that deserves its
own horror movie the next internet meme
that deserves its own horror movie and
you know question that should never have
been asked ever in the world well hey we
are here and we asked it's Omar I hope
you came to play and I hope your answer
is dank no okay Greg your player number
2 we'll start with you alright it's just
funny knowing my choice and their
choices are so different that's because
it's the questions inspired by
Slenderman I went with something that
originated I believe from 4chan and that
is the SCP foundation and when I walked
in here no one knew what the SCP
foundation is so just to be as accurate
as possible and under that movie fights
thing where I read from the paper and
I'm gonna do as quick as possible ok the
SCP foundation it's a secret
organization and trusted by governments
around the globe
to contain and study anomalous
individuals entities locations objects
and phenomena that define natural law
SCP standing for secure contain protect
if left on contained they pose a threat
to humans or at the very least of
humanity's sense of reality and normalcy
so basically imagine an organization
kind of like the men in black but not
limited to just aliens alone and I think
I like this choice because then you can
make a movie that sets up for like a
sci-fi horror anthology franchise I'm
wondering what he wrote every horror
movie that's every horror movie that's a
success I always one make a sequel out
of it the problem with the sequels is
they become repetitive this one you
could set up for an anthology franchise
there because they have all kinds of
weird creatures I'm going to list them
off super quick one of them is scp-173
it's a humanoid statue composed a rebar
concrete and krylon spray paint and it's
stationary when directly observed but
when butt attacks people when line aside
with it is broken that includes blinking
and then some of them are kind of like
Slenderman that I could pull from later
on there's ones that are strange kind of
like a staircase that descends downward
but it's described as a face without a
mouth this currently has about 38,000
users on this
site and yeah I feel like you can make a
lot of films out of this and I'll go
into more details in a second does
anyone on confused I need to explain or
elaborate in that was a decent
explanation SCP various forms of
Nightmare fuel thank you Greg yes sir
alright Ken what do you got
Friday morning 7:00 a.m. for school
chums arrived to pick up our hero
Rebecca she heads to school to start the
last day of school of her life upon
arriving to school to find out schools
protected over by zombie haters Ken
Rebecca and her chums get to Saturday
which comes after man that was a great
trailer Ken who says you need to be
drunk Thank You knapsack look forward to
hear more about that all right mark and
Rico memes talk to us what if the most
popular trusted woman on the planet had
a superpower a terrifying superpower
that she unleashed on her studio
audience yes I'm talking Oprah Winfrey
and the bees me MA
it's been a long time did you go to kill
her be movin it's been a long time since
we've seen Oprah really embrace a really
dynamic performance this is amazing you
have the Bacchanalia of the audience
thinking they're gonna get cars but like
saw or like Hellraiser that's not what
you're getting you're never getting what
you think you're getting killer bees and
you watch is Oprah the mistress of the
bit the hive the queen bee runs around
laughing as people get stung and choked
anaphylactic shock
vomiting convulsions death stingers
blood and oprah just laughs and you know
somewhere
gayle is hiding back there in a suit
ready to hug oprah after the bees have
done their job Gail's wearing a
beekeeper outfit yeah all right fight it
out you guys if you had had Stedman
killing over at the end you would have
got go picture kid but yeah the sequel
look I wrote down notes when Greg was
talking and it ended up just writing
what's happening III we're trying to
pitch a movie here and you've got I know
you got a franchise there but and I know
where it comes from but I don't know
what's going on I'm pale it's basically
a world full of all kinds of strange and
normal entities and then people do
Studies on it inside of a lab and this
has a big following about it there's a
huge mythology dysphoria did krylon do
product placement to be part of that
concrete zombie no notice if ik Lee said
Kryolan I didn't powers is written off
the SCP wiki the best name and
spray-paint
and you said that there are 38,000
people no 38,000 online you online
writing community like it's one of those
- kind of like a Slenderman form from
creepypasta and people pitching stories
yeah there's a similar mythology to this
so that's why I was using the analogy
and like a men in black type of
organization but with weirder creatures
and I think you could do like a David
Lynch type of psychological body horror
movie there might be something
interesting there but this was a
question and from my I interpret it was
memes in the internet being something
popular and since no one here except you
knew what that was and you had to go
into graphic detail with what it was I
don't know what the I don't know what
the brand value is with that because if
you have to you know when you say
Rebecca Black's Friday or Oprah bezel
movies like the queen of the beasts
thing is that was a meme that's made fun
of from the whole cars thing and that
joke is so old already and Rebecca
Black's Friday honestly I kind of don't
want to see a movie that's making fun of
that poor girl because she's a lawyer
are you but you're saying yours is just
men in black with different names 24
million views behind mine and I'm saying
you put Rebecca Black in this she's
fighting haters all right she's going
into school she's got zombies zombie
haters zombie
thank Pritchett have Rebecca on the show
and they and that's great my movie so he
wants to spin off in his own universe
discussions expired by the Slender Man
question though and slenderman's
originates from similar things as the
SCP and here I feel like you could do a
movie of where if you do if you look up
on YouTube people have done short films
about this a variety of short films and
they have millions upon millions of
views so I don't agree with the idea
that people haven't heard of it because
if you type it in on YouTube
there's does plenty of has it gotten
meand or is it merely contained like a
reddit thread I yeah it's been it's been
mean for sure okay I know I would say
he's right in the sense that it's been
mean and that yeah it does it is a thing
it doesn't just because a Draco ethology
- that's not the questions not be the
next Slender Man theme horror movies
Slenderman smart it's just a horror
movie and when I'm say with your says
I'm trying to hear your pitch in an
elevator heading up to my suite office
floor office there Mike you know what
I'm saying the bar the bar I've joined
and I'm not hearing a story about here
in a franchise I've got yeah build you
the world right now I know the first
movie could be where people are brought
into like human test subjects and then
one of the test subjects successfully
breaks out and they're kind of going
through the laboratory of this whole
vast building and then they're
encountering all different kinds of SCPs
but that's based on all the history of
we're talking like based on a based on a
meme what does the meme that your SCP
thing is based on his is based on the
song mine is based on the clip what's
the Slenderman meme exactly even the
fluttering gets meme to the Slender yeah
and CPI has been memed as well sure sure
sure but again I'm just I'm not
gravitated to your story and look I've
got to said open with bees is great
that's funny Washington clip 16 times in
the car in the world joke would die down
so what in terms of a movie you know you
got to give me your hero you gotta give
me this and that I think it falls flat
the big bees come out we got we got a
bad worst version of the birds that's
fine I'm good with that
but I think mine has a hero it has
friends that are gonna die along the way
it has a villain haters of the villains
my friends oh it's got a theme song
built in Friday
your audience is gonna be voting or
rooting for the zombies in that that's I
just would not want to reignite that
poor girls like romantic past she
engaged to a record please no I think
that could open up a fresh room for this
she had to be pulled from school
business of all the abuse she was gonna
dis is this is about that she's gonna be
able to get the performance of a
lifetime when she taps in to the hate
she experienced unlock just a girl
fourteen trying to sing about Friday
Friday gettin down on Friday and her old
life gets it's a horror movie in itself
so now let's pour that in let's pour
that eggs that anger that fear all that
stuff that wouldn't do it into this
movie that people are gonna come back
storm if you lost the lead role with
someone sympathetic maybe mark so I
basically heard about one scene from
your movie the iconic memed
rules
Oprah rules Chicago there is someone
how's that different from now because
she wants just Luciana she lives in Ojai
now okay so she is she is the Lex Luthor
of Chicago everyone can still love her
she does all these great things for the
city but she's taking her enemies with
her telekinetic control of killer bees
and then her best friend Gail finds out
that her that her best friend is evil
and have to try and save her so you get
this this megalomaniac part of it you
get this check on high part of it you
get this friendship like fried green
tomatoes and you get a nature message
about the bees there's so much going on
in this movie dealing with so many flaws
that are in this role this into your
final thoughts you know everyone loves
Oprah everyone's concerned about the
bees there's a great there's a great
nature horror film to be had there it's
been a long time since we've had one and
I don't think this I don't know what I
mean I have never seen a meme from this
so I don't know what has been meme from
it and I just think there's a there's
something in a musical version of zombie
movie of a rebecca black song but she's
so talent for and unlikable I don't
think anyone would would mourn her being
devoured by green alright thank you Mark
Greg final thoughts my idea is the only
one with actual rear real horror roots
these ideas that I'm hearing are like
these these are old
ideas it's like when you see those
Freiburg and Seltzer comedies and then
you're like why are they making jokes
about these things that are so old like
no no one really cares about that
anymore Oprah doesn't have that show
anymore and the Rebecca Black Friday
song was years ago mine is actually
still happening today just because you
guys haven't heard of it doesn't mean
there isn't millions of other people who
haven't heard of it as well it's still
very popular people are still expanding
upon it and it has room for a franchise
and it has room to be actually scary and
terrifying yours are just joke horror
movies based off old things that are
funny thanks Greg kidnaps are we're
trying to pitch movies here we're trying
to have distinct heroes villains and
storylines we do have some sort of
available with mark but I don't know
what happens after the bees released it
it becomes like a fried green tomatoes
kind of movie it's kind of a
relationship picture III I like what
Greg's coming from you got some history
you got some some some worlds to dive
into I just don't hear a story there I
hear thoughts of stories I hear other
stories mine is a horror movie a class
think of the faculty think of even even
the classic you know Halloween or
something you have some kind of a
villain that emerges to take down our
hero who is it's got obstacles and maybe
you know we can't I love mark he's one
of the marking triggers on the Swedish
guys in the world but I'm not gonna say
you know Rebecca Black is unlikable
people like a comeback story this is her
comeback and a message to the world kids
you can overcome the haters you can
fight them and defeat them and make it
to the weekend all right there you go
time how about it we're getting all
memed up what Lana I hope you have a lot
of memes on deck when we come to you
like what are people suggesting it's a
problem Bank over here but first let's
go to uh noise let's go to Dan Byrne
with facts and his thoughts on the
battle I mean I don't really have many
facts other than that Slender Man is
actually hitting theaters this week
checking out see there's a dancing
monkey that reads what's in front of
them
airplanes enough we had Halloween on the
brain this week but you can check out
Slenderman or not I don't know I haven't
seen it but anyway you can check that
out now this was a little this is a
little harder for me I you know I
actually eliminated Greg first in my
mind all because this is about pitching
a movie and I thought Greg pitched a
universe he pitched a concept for a
mythology but I feel like Ken and Mark
where the two that pitched me a movie so
this oh they were the two that I was
thinking about most and between those
two ideas I think Mark's idea made me
laugh the most and I could picture it in
my mind but I think Ken's idea was the
most fully formed I don't know how we
read me the question one more time yes
sir
Slender Man is coming to the theaters
this October erection what's the next
internet meme that deserves its own
horror movie there's its own horror
movie okay I just I think I like and
Draco's idea better I think it has more
potential I'm gonna go I'm gonna go with
mark I'm going with Marla gotcha
all right that's one vote for mark I
hear ya that there wasn't a fully formed
movie there but there was a lot of
detail and thought be behind Gregg's and
that's an interesting world to explore
this was a real toss-up for me but I at
the end of the day I feel like Ken had
the clearest singular movie to me of
Mark's like I love that idea but there
wasn't a whole lot of there there after
that initial scene which was striking
but yeah Ken kind of painted this
picture that out of there was there's
high school like satire like I'm
thinking faculty I'm thinking like I
could see a little bit of like scream in
there just like some different
directions to take this thing and
yeah I think it would kind of be a love
you love to hate it and rebeccablack
winning us over so I'm going ken so it's
one one mark audience vote lawns the
audience is not gonna be any help for
you here because they went SCP they went
with Gregg's
45% to 137 percent for Friday 17% for
Oprah a lot of people in the chat room
really big fans of SCP disappointed in
the rest of the table for not knowing
what it was yeah other memes that came
up a bunch sure mad at gopher FA the
Frog the distracted boyfriend these the
guys looking at the other girls yes salt
Bay he's the guy that's sprinkling the
south of mistake yeah b-movie came up a
bunch Harambee Tide Pods but I think the
most popular suggestion was actual
cannibal Shia LaBeouf people wanted a
cannibal Shia LaBeouf movie finally you
maybe he's already a movie uh how would
you do it as a horror movie I don't know
I just reads what about Space Jam 2 with
crying Jordan meme oh yeah nobody
suggested but I we are all tied up here
what do you do a stab does we keep
changing on this Billy tell me if you
object
I think the consistent rule should be if
there's a tie then the personal opinion
of of our social consultant should be
the tiebreaker you changing it back and
forth yeah I like that would you want to
make let's do some cannon how let's make
some candles yes okay if it's tied 1 1 1
after the audience bowls and a myself
yes you are now and Danielle hopefully
in the future I'll get to decide five
preset wait there try any break good
wedding I have to say I really I liked
Greg's pitch too but I wanted to hear
more of like what was the move like how
are we getting into this world not just
what this world is in terms of food
describe something I think this is the
most cinematic I have to go with Marc
and Rico I really want to see The Oprah
Winfrey attacking innocent people with
all right Marcus I was like I'm gonna
have to really explain what this is for
I can explain a movie posting like what
some of these stories are and that sound
real crazy yeah I was like I'm getting
so hung up on all right I think it came
from 4chan it's its own horror movie
okay so it is one one after two rounds
we are going to round three Ken's at him
NASA yet to get on the board okay
DC announced Supergirl is in development
there it is we got to find a Supergirl
writer yes who should play Supergirl who
should play Supergirl and we are going
to start with the player number three
for question number three kidnap sock
look I know for a fact that this show is
booked in advance and it's based off the
movie news of the week so there's no way
they knew when they reached out to the
three of us fighters a couple weeks ago
to book us that they knew Supergirl and
a Supergirl rider would be here and
directors were the more talented comic
writers out there we know this the book
is out in shops by it but who Craig and
I are up against it right here my choice
is Betty Gilpin who is of course known
to a lot of people right now for her
work in glow as Liberty Bell
Alison Brie's main rival and sometimes
friend in the show I am taking what she
does in the show and putting it into a a
more mature version of Supergirl I know
that's gonna come into play here but
she's got physicality with with layered
emotion she's a great actress
it's been we've seen her work on display
here and I think she's going to make a
more complete modern superhero for a
film audience all right thank you sir
back around the bend to mark and Draco
I'm going after my god
since the character's name is
girl I decided to go with someone who's
actually a girl who's a really talented
actress who I think much like young
Christopher Reeve you signed her for
this movie and she's going to become a
big star we've already seen her building
her career and that's a Sofia Lillis
from it and sharp objects she's actually
a young girl she is if you saw her and
it the performance was amazing she's a
super talented actress it's almost like
watching young Jodie Foster seeing
hoping to see where this talent goes I
think she brings an innocence to with
her that that Karl would have when she
lands on this new planet but she doesn't
bring a naivete she brings a smartness
and a groundedness I mean the fact that
in the movie she's the only one not
afraid of the clown that that girl does
young girl could pull off I'm not scared
of Pennywise cuz my dad's a creep shows
that she has such great instincts and I
think he could have a great performance
that both young people would respond to
especially young girls and I think
people would root for her I think she's
a huge star in the making and I think
you for making this movie you want to
sign her today and she's actually a girl
all right there you go Sofia Lillis from
it and sharp objects Greg time to just
have fun here alright my choice I'm
choosing Jessica Roth she recently
starred in the movie happy look at that
she could totally be Supergirl she
recently starred in the movie happy
deathday which was a box-office success
and she's in pretty much every frame of
that movie and most critics praise the
hell out of her performance there
because it is a wonderful three
dimensional performance that has so much
personality she nails it with the comedy
in that film she nails it with the drama
in that movie I think the theme of me
today is crying at female performances
and she had me crying in that movie too
during happy desert one scene where she
talks with her father that actually had
me crying and two she's someone who kind
of like when Cara first shows up she's
lonely isolated she finds herself by the
end of the movie does and also when it
comes time for her to go up against the
bad guys she has to learn to be tough
and when she does the fight scenes when
she does those moments she is believable
in it she can do the physical work she
can do the comedy she can do the drama
and she's the only one of the three here
that has led her own movie you guys have
supporting act
in an insomnia have someone who can hold
her own without you going I wish
Superman was in this movie and she
proved that with her star turning
performance in happy deathday
all right fight it out y'all go start
earning performance and happy happy
deathday if anyone has ever gone to a
plum house movie because of the actors
in it that's why they keep them so cheap
and though they did it but when they
walked out they were wildly impressed
with her performance of the three years
is the only one I had never heard of I
had to look her up and find her and
track her down again it doesn't matter
SCP remember that ok fine but the
ultimately ultimately oldsman fact here
is she's 31 but he Gilpin 32 they're not
girls they are women and we are seeing
right now in movies about kids actually
casting real kids whether it's sing
street or blockers casting children to
play children is important this isn't
the days of 902 101 a 45 year old Luke
Perry's playing a fresh mouth you
actually have an just and I'm Sophia
Lewis is a great actress you can argue
that she's part of an ensemble in that
movie but you ever think all three of
our choices are great every time she's
on screen and whether whether it's sharp
Bobby's you're it you're you're looking
at her you're you're interested in her
there is so much potential there and I
think she captures the Supergirl part of
it these actresses are both fine
actresses but they're not girls they're
in their 30 what is it I also have a I
get a weird feeling about seeing her in
the Supergirl outfit because she's only
gonna be 17 next year it's a pretty
revealing outfit the way they do those
but a drink of choice is I totally get
where it's coming from there and with
with the general accepted history of
this character but I that I'm trying to
look for the film how I'm trying to look
at the big screen
what DC's already got going on and we
want to get away from CW which has done
a great job Melissa what's in it but
nosiness
has done a spectacular job we want to be
a little bit different from that so I
guess do you go really young and get
another origin story or do you do go to
where kind of the DC films are right now
and already established kind of
characters dealing some things I think
Betty go up and bring some rage some
underlying rage to what she does in glow
or this is a another burgeoning Superman
like character forties and that's not a
comment about that's not aged shaming
her body she just doesn't look like a
girl she could play Cara's mother great
well Kent will give her a job you flick
but but yeah and also to the origin
story part of it no one said that there
needs to be a big origin story in that
in fact if you read my first issue of
Supergirl the origin is rejected why I
think highly recommend everyone read
that I don't think I don't think you
have to be an adult to have a movie ally
but be the lead in a movie I think I
think that when you have Supergirl and
you follow her arc you could you can
have her age as you do sequels but she
needs to be a girl because if she's that
if she's an adult
she's just Superman but a woman just a
female you need to bring in car trying
to not only did she lose everyone she
knew on her planet learned exploded but
she's trying to fit into American high
school that's almost as brutal as the
Phantom Zone so there's so much great
human stuff you can do in this with
balance the superhero stuff I just don't
think you can do with 32 year old 33 old
woman wandering I think you can because
I think Jessica Roth has a very youthful
quality about her she placed someone a
lot younger than her actual age in happy
deathday and I'm gonna bring him back to
this she's the only one who has
successfully led her own movie support
least these two actresses are great I
think all three of our choices are great
actors there's no I don't think there's
any denying that but when I think of
like Betty Gilpin for example I think of
only those qualities that you're talking
about which is you know the tough rage
girl and she's known for that and I
think Sophia Lillis is a good choice but
I don't really think she has the
Supergirl look I think Jessica Roth
embodies both
elements of what you guys are talking
about I think she has all the qualities
and she also has I don't want to see her
in a third Super Girl sequel when she's
52 years old
I will counter this thing that the
starting a movie thing here this is a
different time a different age where
where movie and performers sometimes do
jump down the TV wood we were down to TV
was kind of this thing it's not the case
it's streaming glow as popular glow has
a movement behind it and dedicated fans
who are affected by the message and you
take that's how a Betty Gilpin would
then go to the big Tom Holland didn't
lead any movie when you spider and he
was plugged into this bigger kind of
already existing character and moving if
with the right script or right team
behind it that's X factors for all these
choices I think Betty Gilpin could
easily slide into that with with an
award nomination behind her I'm not
saying that Betty Gilpin's a bad actress
no I don't think either I mean I've
never seen that movie so I can't comment
on her action but I don't think that
it's about about level of town I think
ultimately you know the if we're gonna
say all three of these are equally
talented women it's about age and
appropriateness for a character you know
you're not gonna cast I don't feel a lil
is to play Mother Teresa
and you're not gonna cast a 32 year old
or a 33 year old woman to play a 17 year
old but do we know she's playing a 17
year old super girl if she's she's over
18 she's superwoman but neither of these
can remain so Supergirl she's not 17 not
talking about the show no but I'm saying
but at some point that characters got to
get older and go to maybe she's dealing
with that maybe she's dealing with with
with a ageism in superhero worlds maybe
she's maybe this is what I'm saying for
the big screen something darker deeper
you know and go ahead and roll this into
your vital phone I think that's what my
thought is here and when trying to put
this out for a a a cinematic choice in
the story and who can embody a different
choice than what's already been out
there which is the CW series look what
they did you know sometimes they
couldn't get away from the flash
comparisons when they went maybe more
closer to to that age I want something
different I want something with more
nuance I want an actress who brings some
physicality to what she can do up there
think of gal gadot gal gadot Gail I'm
thinking of be still
you want someone who could match her on
the screen and that is why my choice
Betty köppen I think is the best one
thanks Ken mark um that's again I think
that these actresses all have talent but
I think that it's Supergirl and you want
a girl that's age-appropriate either of
these women could be villains in the
movie but if you're doing a movie called
Supergirl and you're starting with her
there's a there's an innocence and a
sense of wonder and a sense of depth to
Sofia Lillis that betrays her years I
think she could bring the humanity of
the performance and still have that
sense of wonder and that sense of
discovery that I just don't think these
either these women can they both they
both look great but they don't look like
they're young women they look like they
are they could play your mom alright
thank you Mark Greg well mark hasn't
seen my actress has actually seen the
performance so I I it's like to to
criticize her like that anyway look I
think that Supergirl needs to have a
wide range of qualities and I feel like
she can do the toughness that Betty
Gilpin brings I feel like she hadn't
happy deathday she portrays that
innocence and wonder that mark is
talking about and she also portrays in
that movie
she shows comedy-drama a whole bunch of
range and she looks the most like
Supergirl out of everyone yes he's
called Supergirl but we don't know for
sure that she's gonna be the teen
Supergirl that's why I was bringing up
the show not to say that's gonna be
based on the show but that shows called
Supergirl and it has a woman who's not a
teenager obviously so we don't know I
think in terms of she's still 10 years
younger than either of these my final
thought so I think in terms of what
we're doing right here
I feel like Jessica Roth is the one who
impose already shown all the qualities
that Supergirl needs from physicality to
looks to comedy to drama to top every
every quality you guys are talking about
she has already demonstrated that and is
the only one who has let her own movie
showing she could do it without needing
some male counterpart to back her time
all right Wow what's road
nerve-racked young woman from Krypton
Dan facts please yeah well I can kind of
loop my fact into my my my pick if that
sure yeah I mean I think that that the
the age point was such a key part of
Mark's argument and looking at I know
I'm gonna get her her name wrong but
Melissa been finished been os/2 is the
current supergirls twenty nine years old
so she's actually very close to the age
of the to Ken's and Greg's pics and I
was with mark for most of this but I
think that so much of the arm it was
just based on the age of the character
and the age of the actress and the age
of the other two actresses and I was on
board for a lot of it but Greg won me
over in the end just in the sense of he
took both of their arguments and said
why his pick an bodied the strengths of
both of them the toughness the Wonder
looping back to their previous work a
little more Greg ended up winning me
over in the end so I'm gonna go with
Greg I like Dan yeah Dan I have some
really similar thoughts to yours cuz
Greg just kept fighting through the bell
he like just from start to finish
mark had great points I mean mentioning
when you brought up her not being afraid
of it
it's that really started to win me over
like right out of the gate in fact mmm
you know what just thinking about it
dan I'm not gonna I started to get
swayed by your 29 years year old fact
that you dropped but you know what I'm
gonna pull back from going too overboard
with that and go back to my initial
thought gray Ken I can't give it to you
that's right yeah I went to research the
fight today I started reading his issue
all right so I understand you know I'm
flip-flopping like a sweaty politician
at a debate but right now I gotta go
mark on Draco I gotta go mark on Draco
and give it to the audience cuz we show
the honest thing ago because
your opening salvo combined with the age
I thought you played nice catch up and
you fought till the end valiantly going
with Mark lon we got one one right here
between a mark and Greg don't tell me
it's Ken no only 14% of the boat this
time in second place Greg with Jessica
Raab 35% of the voice 50% of the viewers
went with Mark and Sofia Lillis so
Marcus the point damn Jerry go other
suggestions chloë grace moretz Sophie
Sophie cooks it from the kings of movies
really James on you Taylor joy saoirse
ronan melissa Benno's our most popular
among eight they all the fans want to
see her come over from the CW and the
name came up a lot Nicolas Cage is
finally his chance to play a son or
daughter of Krypton yes my pick for
Supergirl would have been the crying
Jordan meme okay um I think she's fine I
think I don't think she has the
physicality at all I like how she reads
is very delicate gotcha on emotionally
but I think she's a great actress oh you
have avenged Josh but Kouga I didn't
good sir I might come to you for some
opinions here but we are on to the speed
round mark and Draco with two points
Greg albo is one point let's do this
really just care to put up a good fight
with you okay again how the speed round
works I will ask a question yes sir
first person to answer will get to
elaborate on their answer first you got
20 seconds 20 seconds and then 10 second
rebuttal 10 second rebuttal it's two one
mark first player to four points wins
the day all right Greg you ready yes sir
mark film it yes sir let's do it the
Oscars announced they will be giving out
a new popular film Oscar what should
have won best popular movie if it was a
category last year Wonder Woman
it all right you know Wonderwoman
vers it ok Greg we hurt you ever since
we get home you got 20 seconds it begins
as soon as you start speaking Wonder
Woman was the first successful female
led superhero movie that really made a
huge impact for the DC films for the
superhero genre in total and is causing
a shift in the DC movies in general I
really think Gallagher dog gave a
performance that we all were really
expecting her to do a great job and she
did that movie brings a lot of tearful
moments to keep Harper around the tears
were in thought to your film moments a
lot of great action both of these are
great movies but it took a brand stephen
king that was known for schlocky bad
horror films and not only took a book
that everyone loved it brought in a cast
of kids that you actually believed were
really friends it was more stand by me
than horrid elevated that and it's a
movie that opened in August the deaths
the zone of the movies and made 700
million dollars worldwide without China
the movie resonated with I would say
that's part of the failure of it though
is the fact that it felt more like a
stand by me than a horror movie
I feel like when you watch Wonder Woman
it gives you exactly what you wanted and
more whereas it a lot of people too
walked out of it going it kinda doesn't
give you the horror elements that you're
looking for when you watch that film I
completely disagree it has the heart and
the soul that makes you invested in
these kids it elevates horror it's not
simply a bunch of horny teenagers
getting killed one by one it's about
this group of friends and it's evocative
of all of our childhoods and friendships
being channeled to this horror movie who
how about it all right what do we what
do you think right down the stretch for
most of the time I was with Greg on this
one and Wonder Woman would have been my
sort of personal choice from last year
but I have to say I thought marks final
statement was really strong and he
responded really well to the point that
Greg made oh it is it's both stand by me
sort of style and that makes the hard
work better so I'm going with mark okay
you know I see that I thought Greg took
this one in my mind I thought his
opening salvo laid out so many more
points than mark was able to deliver
about his film so for in on recoverable
opening salvo I go Greg so it's one one
Merl am waiting there's a slight factual
errors at it over to September early
September instead of August but to
really sway Mike because it wasn't
hinged on that
oh man this is taut I think I think
Greg's opening salvo was good but I
think it was too insular and it was too
focused on the DC Universe in the comic
book universe and I think that marks
were marks arguments were much more
about why the movie itself was you know
it took the it took a brand and
transcended it I think mark actually
swayed me so I'm gonna go work alright
mark takes that point it is 3 1 and
Draco it is game point and Draco right
now Greg you need this to keep it going
sir all right here we go
James Wan confirmed that no other
Justice League members will be showing
up in Aquaman we want to know who's the
better Justice League character so far
Aquaman or flash flash you can give him
this point I can't argue for Aquaman
there you go I hope the movies great I
just don't like that interpretation of
Aquaman so I'm just gonna be called
ronzo Aquaman's who tweets now all right
it is three two it's still game point
mark mark with a questionable tactic
right there I might lose but I was
honest all right I will win mark
borrow and steal movie 43 is the best
comedy okay here we go it is three two
still game point mark Greg needs us to
keep it going Robert Redford's hanging
it up for good what is the best ever
Robert Redford performance the natural
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid
Sundance Kid
okay Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid
and the natural we heard mark first you
can begin whenever you're feeling it as
a person who's not a fan of sports are
very sporty the natural is one of my
favorite movies of all time because it
transcends being a baseball movie and it
takes in it takes the King Arthur myth
and grounds that on it you've got Glenn
Close you've got Kim Basinger giving a
great performance you've got Robert
Redford leaning into himself as he
starts to age and start aging out of the
leading man look it's a performance that
is both meta and extremely fresh at the
same time what was the question exactly
again yes Robert Redford's hanging it up
for good what is the best ever Robert
Redford performance I feel like you said
a lot of good things about the movie the
natural but I saw Butch Cassidy and the
Sundance Kid when I was a kid and that
was the performance that always stuck
with me he was a guy who everyone wanted
to be and I think when you think of
Robert Redford performances you tend to
go back to movies like Butch Cassidy and
the Sundance Kid his performance in that
film is so subtle and so badass at the
same time I will say you know that's
butch Cassidy's a decent movie as well
but the age that the time in his career
were bred for gave his performance is so
much a commentary on him as an actor as
well as an everyman that we can all
relate to
I just think that the Sundance Kid
performance is one that's a lot more
iconic it's the one that has stuck with
the hearts of millions of Americans the
natural is a film I don't even really
remember that I think a lot of people
don't really remember Sundance Kid is a
character that all right Wow good stuff
no one said all the President's Men
other channel Maya Johnson
okay yes they'd never seen the nesting
[Music]
we got what we got and you know two
classic Redford's two Redford height of
powers iconic performances here but yeah
I felt like Greg you were talking in
broader strokes and even though you were
hitting a lot about the film
I thought you zeroed in on Redford and
nailed that with your answer mark so I
go mark with the natural Dan Merle yeah
I think I would agree with all the
President's Men to only because they
made one cited phone conversations
compelling what's example thing to do in
a movie but that's not the question and
it's got a great subject matter
press great movie it's a generalistic
thriller which I enjoy I agree I think
that Mark had it nailed on the specifics
of the performance itself why that one
distinguished itself on the rest of his
career Greg suppose a little more broad
didn't quite get me so I would also go
with Mark yeah that means mark and Draco
takes it
[Applause]
well played everybody mark is a bit more
info about where people can find your
awesome work well you can find super
Early's are the two variant covers this
is the regular cover by Terry Dotson
this is the cover by the great Amanda
Connor this came out yesterday so please
give it a shot it spins out of Brian
Bendis his Man of Steel stuff I'm very
very proud I get to work with Kevin
Maguire who is the legendary Justice
League artist so it's oh I'm still
pinching myself that I get to do this
you can also follow me on twitter at
mark and draco or on facebook and in a
week from Saturday we're doing yes 10th
anniversary which is hilarious it's
hilarious Thanks you are in the LA area
the tournament of nerds it is our 10th
anniversary it's a comedy debate show
basically who's more awesome who'd win
in a fight and stuff like you know
Captain America versus Justin Bieber or
yeah weird real and fictional
celebrities and characters battling it
out and one last thing next week my
match at the movie Schmoe down with
Ethan Irwin goes up so if you want to
see something that scared the hell out
of me alright mark and Draco getting his
money's worth of plugs Greg Alba you
know you did not win today but you you
brought it and yeah a a fine sophomore
effort yeah I'm on the real rejects on
YouTube and I had a great time today I
mean like I said before coming in here
mark is someone I tend to agree with
when I've liked you know on on the
internet and Ken is hilarious and he's
still a fighter who also intimidates me
so today I just really focused on having
a good time and I'm off with a good
fight
glad we have got to have that Supergirl
discussion cuz I was having a little
panic attack in there but yeah you can
find me on YouTube Twitter Instagram and
thanks for watching in heck yeah Kim
naps off always a pleasure
lover fighter bon vivant fan of
sharknado thank you for always bringing
it I love coming back into these
hallowed halls fun fighting both you
guys today mark and rigor and I just had
a interview online app select files
podcast mark really opened up about his
career life you can check that out of
the knapsack files I've got the
afternoons with Josh and Ken that's josh
mokuba
we I got my Instagram TV my motivations
can every morning Monday through Friday
will fail to get you through the day and
September 8 if you're local - we've got
the big live movie trivia Schmo Don it
is always fun these guys are there you
can come meet me and you know I'll
probably already have a beer but you can
buy me another one
heck yeah he'll never say no to that cat
nap sock Dan Merle I just imagining Ken
like that is the quote if he was ever on
a billboard with like a motto next to
him that is what we're kin that suck
I'll probably already have a beer but
you can buy me another one a Passat nice
what would what would your billboard
quote be Dan oh boy probably that yeah I
don't know Dan I you've you're really
rich when it comes to jaws shirts shirt
actually there's a there's a great place
you can find them online it's called out
of print Maura and I found this booth at
comic-con which is why I love walking
the floor it's not for like all the
Funko pops you find these little booze
it's a place this place called
out-of-print and they make shirts out of
like book covers this is like the book
like the hardback book cover for jaws
and they do like classic books and stuff
but yeah thank you this is a newsreel
what's that out of print
yeah I'll work it on and I love that
they're always like something I hadn't
seen before Dan I got your billboard
motto I'll probably be all right
probably already be wearing a jaws shirt
but you can buy me another one anyway
there you go excellent I think it's out
of print clothing calm and yeah they got
it's not a plug thing I just this is the
really cool shirt and I like these small
things that go to comic conventions the
way on the drive home but they should
sponsor this show enough probably
Claude Harris thank you for holding it
down being the conduit the voice of the
people where can people find you know
they should go to Twitter at L ons
that's where to find me and also I read
a newsletter about streaming TV and
movies everything cool that's happening
on Netflix Hulu Amazon HBO all those
just go to inside coms that's streaming
to find it heck yeah
thank you sir it was pleasure to have
you and I'm Hal Rudnick you can find me
on Instagram and Twitter both at Hal
Rudnick where I'm just talking a lot of
dumb stuff and a lot of fun stuff about
movies TV and whatnot I want to thank
you for watching movie fights thank you
everybody mark well played by his calm
books and tune back in next week for
some more movie fights thanks for
watching bye
you